stellt euch vor wir wollen das beste
restaurant in düsseldorf testen gehen in
einen supermarkt fahren rolltreppe
runter und dessen drei stunden lang
lassen am ende ein haufen kohle da ob
sich das gelohnt hat sie freunde
herzlich willkommen zu diesem video ich
weiß gar nicht wie ich dieses video
anfangen soll ich bin wirklich
nachhaltig beeindruckt von dem was heute
passiert ist wir waren nämlich im besten
restaurant in düsseldorf im setzkasten
einem michelin regierten restaurant und
ich habe auf eure ratschläge gehört und
habe im vorfeld keinerlei rezensionen
gelesen ich habe nicht einmal geschaut
und deshalb machen wir das ganze jetzt
ja natürlich trotzdem unvoreingenommen
seien und wir gucken mal gemeinsam
bereiten also restaurant setzkasten
platz eins von 1371 wir sehen da oben
wirklich verrückte dich ist die dadurch
vision und haben vier euro zeichen
werden wir sehen wie teuer mich das
ganze zu stehen kommt und 5 sterne aus
342 bewertung also wirklich das
komplette kontrastprogramm zu meinem
letzten restaurant test den wir auch
undercover gemacht haben wo wir im
schlechtesten restaurant kölns war
natürlich denkt wir gucken jetzt aber
mal in die bewertung also ein stern ist
fast eine beleidigung der also nur für
verständnis man kann maximal drei haben
und das haben wir nach handvoll
restaurants auf der welt so weit nicht
das was ein glücksmoment ein toller
abend unser abend in diesem restaurant
war ein erlebnis macht einfach spaß
perfekt leute ihr merkt schon höchste
töne wir gucken ob überhaupt schlechte
rezensionen existieren also ihr seht
hier 320 mal ausgezeichnet einmal
ungenügend das will was heißen wir haben
auf jeden fall gesehen leute es ist dumm
gut bewertet und ob es auch dumm lecker
ist wie man so schön sagt sehen wir
jetzt viel spaß so freuen wir sind jetzt
jeden moment da und nicht ganz kurz noch
mal ein paar worte verlieren ich uns
einfach zu krank das ist gerade einfach
meinen job so und ich fahre um 12 uhr im
sternerestaurant hätten um das zu
bewerten für euch und ich muss einfach
ein echter immer danke sagen auch wenn
ein sentimentales aber ich habe wirklich
gehört gerade glücklich das ist sehr
sehr nah danke dass ihr dabei seid danke
dass ihr das möglich macht und an der
stelle auch wenn ihr den kanal
abonnieren würde würde ich mir eine
große freude machen das zeigt dass sie
die wertschätzung für die ganze arbeit
die jetzt seit neuestem auch noch mehr
in videos research & whitney geiler
leute gehen jetzt erst mal gucken wir
fürs tor von außen an
was schon mal sehr nice ist wir haben
angerufen gemerkt wie sieht es mit
parken aus und man kann jetzt
tatsächlich kostenlos parken in diesem
tag auch wenn es wahrscheinlich schon
denken es wird ein bisschen teurer
insgesamt heute aber so was hat man auch
im kleinen viel gute faktor irgendwie
hier irgendwo
angelika es ist nicht perfekt
ausgeschildert da sehen wir auch schon
einfach nur wieder einmal außen herum
gegeben hat sind wir eigentlich ihre
kinder project x die kamera ein bisschen
und grohmann muss durchsehen edeka also
ist jetzt nicht luxuriös aber ich könnte
mir vorstellen wir reden halt von einer
restaurant klasse wo sich alles
unterscheiden muss so weit weg ich das
jetzt aber vielleicht ist es für leute
die sonst hat in den frankfurter tor von
googles geil dass man so erstmal durch
die gemüseabteilung doch irgendwie ist
das auch bundes orie wer bis hin zu
begeistern
hallo wir hatten einen tierschutz weiter
so schickt man gerne essen also es gibt
ja zwei optionen wurde uns gesagt haben
telefon
[Musik]
wir haben ja den weg aus köln auf uns
genommen haben würden wir wohl das
business lunch schon auf wen man hat das
sind wird muss der summe bedeutet
einkaufen einfach auslegungssache haben
wir aber eine ganz aber somit unsere
plätze in der kirche dass das
schottische lagers blue firmen tun
usd am sehr exklusiven zutaten schon mal
eine kaffee hat mich ja auch schon
eingesetzt aber was ist kaffee ajax
schmackhaft das in so hätten schmecken
wir müssen noch fahren sehr fasziniert
die dort
was passiert dann damit kann man es
jetzt einmal standfestigkeit im winter
tag ist schon eine komische sachen und
ich will gar nicht auf namen zu benutzen
wer also erst mal ganz schön fies ist
nicht im gewinn enthalten teams so
richtig lese teilen wir 55 will das
schon
man dachte viel herum
wir haben ja jetzt gerade einfach eine
erklärung dafür man muss nicht mal man
muss nicht selbst jetzt einfach schon
auf guten appetit
relativ geraden mit politisch
angespannten situation mit kirsten davor
schritte ja das klingt jetzt schon sechs
reagenzglas haben geschenkt bekommen die
drei sachen
messer und zwangen gezeigt das ist
einfach eine aubergine und das soll
jetzt so schön frostig schmecken
auch hier können
mit dem texter das hier sind von der
textur vom geschmack sind wir bevor wir
an unsere vorspeise zu essen haben wir
schon so eine komplette germans die
akteure ich freue mich darüber zusammen
kriegt da können auch so ein klassisches
20 minuten video display mit der küche
wir haben ja beim nächsten mal schon
durch raming ist glaube ich bei so eine
große sache sind am lachen
mit 5 50 euro für ein mittagessen
wenn du überlegst du gard hören bekommen
sie so ich meine wir stehen am anfang
aber wenn du dir taste mal nächsten also
danke sehr
hausgemacht
tomaten erst mal wieder
es ist wahr machen kein gang hat auf
jeden fall ist so ein gewicht drin kurze
frage an dich also bei mir des abgeholt
sni des körpers also wohl eher schwach
bin ich bin ja jemand so viel essen
frankenhöhe auch deshalb nicht sagt
werden dann ist es eigentlich scheißegal
wie geil es ist weil wir müssen sowohl
ich sage ich für leute die verbrauchten
essen haben zu erleben meistens können
und wir haben dementierte
auch wahrlich das ganz kurz für meine
hinter story bei allen beteiligten
das 15 gemacht bevor es anschließend
kehre man heute schärfen sie waren ganz
große traum ist hier ist derzeit
wirklich leisten kann ich habe schon
viel erlebt aber du hast ja auch noch
mehr erlebt wie wird es da einstufen
gerade
143 angela krug an der präzision
alles zusammen
supergut dankeschön man muss aber jetzt
passt
das ist nicht was für jeden ja oft
nichts in der brühe
das ist schlecht so erleben ich höre das
jetzt die krank eigentlich der praktiken
aber anders und natürlich keller sind
vor gelernt dass ich überrascht dass
küchen niemand
das ist einfach nur nach also der märkte
weiter ich hätte wirklich nicht dazu
bereit ich nicht kann muss das
verarbeiten der kein schnippchen
ich kann nicht mehr für sein also kann
ich jetzt würde ich gerne mehr
das ist glaube er braucht vor release
und dem 1
verschiedene
wie kommen wir kommen nicht mehr aus dem
staunen über so etwas würde irgendwie
bereichen der stadt wieder irgendwas mit
wir schicken das gerne sowohl im haupt
damit dass die bundeswehr noch einen
kleinen gag burnout wir haben gegen
celtic artist zustände schon zum 1
ich habe plötzlich richtig geschnitten
sagt er ich dachte wirklich nach dem
ganzen mist und so kannte kochen mit
dachten wirklich kann so ein bisschen
kochen
dazu kann man also wunderschöne haben
sternkopf selbst andere branche vor
unseren augen um normal das getränk dazu
sich auf eine absprache
[Musik]
microsoft ist natürlich der perfekte
kontrast ist letzte woche von der weg so
ich will nicht dass ausstattung
wir haben ist eigentlich optimal
eingestimmt auf diesen besonderen tag
kein schlechtes leben werden natürlich
auch weiterhin schlechten restaurants
und meinen wir sehen es nicht abgehoben
geworben wird kommen und wird gut
wir sind schon seit zeiten freuen das
ding ist 55 euro
diese bisher zweistündige reise gekostet
hat gekostet hat geht es um abends in
eine bar im club ist was schlechtes so
schnell schnell davon
das kann es nicht vergleichen wäre das
ein experiment leben so erzählt er und
sagt nicht ich hab mir speziell motors
rhein gezogen wurde erzählt zu können
menschen schaffen kann
nabucco wird kommt es springt sich jetzt
auch inzwischen szene reden
danke danke als die version
darauf steht der bürger
eine buttermilch und dann haben wir
einmal macht sind wir von der hamburger
da ist einfach so aus respekt verläuft
die große in so einem kunstvollen
verlaub das ist chronisch und natürlich
nicht zu vergessen die geprüften märkte
auf grün grün grün grün geplant ist auch
dass der kasten er gesagt hat waging
oder steak in seinem körper das ist so
krank kommt ich probier den kopf vom
boden
sofern die hoffentlich klar kommt
richtig sauer ist er normalerweise ein
buddha wird direkt auf das ist
vielleicht 15 natürlich auch sehr sehr
gut 75 prozent andere sachen machen sich
nicht so einfach sagen wir du kannst du
heute ich hab doch das war ja klar wir
haben noch vier verschiedene teller
bekommt nach belieben crema catalana
falsche und liebe ein russisches bisher
mit kondensmilch die asiatische bisher
was ser soll heute geht es um einen
katalog dessen jetzt auch noch schön
übertrieben werke aber stand fest
und ich sage es nicht soweit dies nicht
stimmt sondern weil es weiß dass es
stimmt also
[Musik]
so krank torleute alter was war das denn
bitte gerade ich kann es einfach noch
nicht so richtig fassen auf der gesamten
rückfahrt wir haben voll wenig
gesprochen eric und ich wir waren
einfach nicht fertig das war dass man
fühlt sich wie nach einer massage mann
plötzlich das hätte man einen kleinen
aber sehr entspannten urlaub genossen
das ist jetzt alles nicht übertrieben
ich weiß das klingt vielleicht krass
aber man muss es selbst erlebt haben und
ich bin einfach geflasht gesät meine
ganzen rezensionen gleich noch aber ich
kann nur sagen ich habe so etwas noch
nicht erlebt also viel spaß mit der
rezension und noch mal wie am anfang
gesagt danke dass ich das machen darf
und erleben wird abseits der tatsache
dass das restaurant setzkasten das beste
in düsseldorf sein soll habe ich mich
vorab bewusst nicht weiter mit dem
restaurant beschäftigt so waren wir nach
unserer anreise aus köln zunächst
überrascht als wir uns nach dem
verlassen des aufzugs in einem
supermarkt wiederfanden
nach kurzer suche wurden wir nach einem
gang durch die feinkostabteilung des
supermarktes sehr freundlich und
entspannt begrüßt wir hatten das große
glück am chef's table zu sitzen und
erhielten so einblick in die herstellung
unseres business lunch sowohl in der
küche also auch bei den wechselnden
kellnern die uns im laufe unseres
besuches betreuten merkte man dass alle
spaß an ihrem job haben und zu keinem
zeitpunkt eine angestrengte stimmung
herrschte
doch nun zum essen neben den vier zu
erwartenden gängen wurden wir so oft aus
der küche gegrüßt dass wir nach unserem
aufenthalt eigentlich sehr gute freunde
sein müssten
ich habe nach gezählt das waren
insgesamt fünf von vorspeisen grüße aus
der küche und aufmerksamkeiten ich würde
an dieser stelle gerne einzelne gänge
hervorheben aber kein gang stand dem
anderen im geschmack oder raffinesse
nachdem die menü planung verwob alles so
ineinander dass das große ganze und
wunschlos glücklich zurück gelassen wir
haben kulinarische höhepunkte erlebt und
einen angenehmen mittag in einer
entspannten atmosphäre genossen das muss
einer der besten wenn nicht der beste
restaurant besucht gewesen sein den ich
je hatte
5 von 5 punkten das war es jetzt aber
auch wirklich leute danke fürs zu sehen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video
macht's gut